the way that we train sales a lot of
people train Rapport building first they
train the script top to bottom but if
someone knows how to do the first half
of the script and they don't know the
second half of the script the likely
that they can close is zero if someone
doesn't have Rapport and they don't know
the opening questions but they know how
to close the likel they could close is
greater than zero my belief from a
selling perspective is that only time
you actually make a statement is when
you sell the vacation then after that
you ask objections happen time money fit
each one of those we always loop back
they give us the thing we overcome it
and we say great so now you're ready
whatever the closing question is soon as
someone says yes we stop selling